on mange avec les yeux oui c'est vrai
alors voici comment de simples plats mis
sur leur trente six deviennent encore
plus appétissant
l'idée c'est de mettre vraiment
l'ingrédient valeur
simplifiée faut pas trop en mettre
parfois faut juste mieux choisir c'est
de l'art éphémère
conçoit le dit mardi au mercredi soir
nos soupers peuvent être bon et aussi
très appétissant
souvent on mange avec nos yeux
depuis longtemps le style de dressage de
notre assiette les jours de semaine
c'est la fameuse technique des trois tas
en réserve et de la cafétéria était
l'idée d'être wata c'est comme ça qu'on
a toujours fait puis le côté visuel est
peut-être moins important au quotidien
lac mollahs en plus d'être chef est un
styliste culinaire réputé des conseils
il en a à revendre et si on commençait
par le commencement on met la table
quatre bonnes apprend les plus beaux
verres à eau qu'on a dans une fois les
ustensiles au lieu de les mettre
traditionnelles -je bien un petit truc
une branche de quelque chose les dépose
là-dessus ensemble amusez vous avec ça
c'est vous c'est vous qui décidez
la couleur des assiettes peut être un
atout ou l' inverse si vous avez trop de
dessins sur votre assiette il peut avoir
un conflit visuel avec votre garniture
d'assiette souvent choisi nos assiettes
unies la base là c'est le blanc mont
blanc moi c'est le crème ou le gris on
essaie d'harmoniser quand même les
couleurs on peut aller un gros contrat
ce ou en harmonie légère de couleurs
dont pourrait utiliser une planche en
bois par exemple c'est le fun ça peut
rester convivial je pense qu'on peut
faire une présentation qui est la leur à
la maison
le chef martin juneau nous dresse un
fils est sûrement de deux façons ça va
être de tout simplement centric nos
ingrédients puis les mettre un par
dessus les autres sans nécessairement
aller dans la tour de pise la tour de
pise faut l'éviter celleneuve souvent
l'idée des étages et de créer un
piédestal pour la vedette on veut que ce
soit visuellement intéressant mais on
veut que ce soit surtout très bon puis
des fois quand c'est tout et chaud tous
égards d'un peu plus haut au chaud aussi
ma mère un bissau se coter à la mise sur
mon là moi ce que je vais faire la seule
différence si je prends mon saumon puis
je le dépose est dessus ok pour en l'air
le côté peau va ajouter à mon avis aux
visuels qui j'avais des oignons marinés
puis un peu d'artichaut ou j'ajoute
plein d'huile d'olive fait que ça
finisse une sauce qui est vraiment
intéressant
pour le poisson en particulier ça fait
presque méditerranéen c'est simple on
réinvente rien on ne dirait
d'accompagnement puis des journaux
quelque chose qui flashent un petit peu
plus loin on va garder les mêmes
systèmes mais juste travailler une
présentation différente avec le saumon
martin nous fait maintenant des langues
est épaisse sampo seront juste laissé un
côté coloré cette fois ci il utilise un
emporte-pièce pour le riz visuellement
on va pouvoir aller complètement
ailleurs c'est justement ça va faire en
sorte que ça reste ça va être beau c'est
un cercle au centre de l'assiette
pot de yogourt ramequins boîte de temps
ou même des emporte-pièces à biscuits
peuvent être rigolo pour les yeux des
enfants au repas
amusez vous avec les formes c'est comme
une sculpture ou fait une sculpture
mangeas faudrait qu'on va chercher un
côté visuel différent
rendu là une vraie juste la sauce puis
le dense que si je vais la mettre
vraiment sur les déçus c'est les mêmes
ingrédients le même type de cuisson
juste une présentation qui se trouve à
être un petit peu plus travaillé ici qu
ici on a des purées on pourrait mettre
juste une cuillérée dans l'assiette puis
après ça avec une spatule on passe on
pourrait même rajouter un filet d'huile
d'olive sur la viande ou dans l'assiette
pour faire un beau trait
si on a du fromage par exemple le micro
plane c'est un objet dont je peux plus
me passer c'est tellement fin on
pourrait rappeler des noix même auprès à
l'ipp ça devient une espèce de neige
qui le filaient pas maintenant deux
types de dressage pour notre filet de
porc c'est très beau on n'est pas obligé
de docteurs en orgie de couleurs
des fois c'est ça qu'ils font c'est ce
qui est beau le monochrome donc en met
l'emphase sur un seul type de couleurs
qui finalement tout un équilibre et puis
ça devient vraiment intéressant
visuellement je trouve ça manque de
légumes la blonde le manque d'eau vers
j'aime bien faire des gros
accompagnement à côté où les gens se
servent un wiki mesures au sein de
l'attaqué mais donc ça pourrait être
vraiment un gros bol daegu verre au bar
super simple qu'on a notre dose et
légumes puis tout le monde est content
surtout nos yeux
le j'ai fait des tranches l'idée serait
de jouer avec l'ordre des ingrédients ce
qu'on va faire c'est ajouter des petit
teaser ben on va à ces années les pommes
de terre 27 fois par dessus donc la même
sauce miel moutarde je vais en met un
petit peu mieux dans ce cas ci je fais
vraiment un très circulaire en général
c'est l'aliment qui doit ressortir
gagnants visuellement de ce juste de
prendre une carotte de taille moyenne
l'a coupé en deux on les cuit comme sont
les soto beurre et on les présente sur
le long comme ça c'est une carotte
simple orange elle est différente c'est
encore la forme d'une carotte ça vous
faire l'effet graphique vachement
intéressant ce que vous aimez ce qui
vous fait plaisir l'idée leur souvent
c'est au delà des tendances et tous à
créer vos propres tendances
[Musique]